suite à la vidéo sur mon bac+ 8 j'ai
rencontré plusieurs difficultés dans le
monde scientifique que je souhaitais
vous partager car oui 8 années d'études
dans les mathématique ne garantit en
rien un emploi à vie derrière que
fait-on après d'ussi longues études que
deviennent nos recherches est-ce autant
recherché que ça dans le monde du
travail je vous délivre toutes les
réponses dans cette vidéo est-ce
véritablement rentable d'être à bac plus
et si je vous disais que vous pourriez
être le prochain Steve Jobs sans aller
plus loin que le bac devenir
entrepreneur ce n'est pas une affaire de
diplôme mais de passion de détermination
et d'innovation ce métier peut être
rentable peu importe votre cursus
scolaire alors pourquoi m'être tué à
faire un doctorat pendant que
j'enseignais au lycée c'était une perte
de temps déjà il ne faut pas oublier que
l'essentiel n'est pas d'avoir le plus
haut diplôme mais bien de choisir un
métier dans lequel on se sent utile
valorisé et passionné car la clé de
votre réussite passe par votre
implication et motivation par contre si
vous êtes attiré par l'argent en moyenne
les stats ne trompent pas les
travailleurs titulaires d'un master
gagnent en moyenne 47 % de plus que la
moyenne nationale tandis que ceux qui
quittent l'école sans diplôme gagnent 26
% de moins oui vous avez bien entendu
près de la moitié de plus dans mon cas
lorsque j'ai passé l'agrégation de
mathématiques pour enseigner au lycée
pendant 7 ans j'ai commencé directement
au salaire moyen des Français 2587 € qui
est au-dessus du salaire médian à 2187
€. mais qu'en est-il pour le bac + 8
aujourd'hui la chute est violente car on
n'y gagne rien un jeune chercheur gagne
5525 € par mois en moyenne dans le
public et un peu plus dans le privé on
peut se dire que c'est rentable car
c'est utile à vie mais pas du tout car
en terminant votre doctorat vous
commencerez à travailler entre 27 et 30
ans alors qu'avec un diplôme d'ingénieur
vous pouvez débuter dès vos 23 ans ces 3
qu années d'ancienneté Vous auriez pu
les prendre dans un job qui vous aurit
été mieux payé avec le temps sans parler
des promotions par exemple dans les
métiers de l'IT voilà la grille des
salaires par ancienneté avec vos 3 qu
année dans le privé vous aurez déjà
gagné plus de 600 € de mensualité
facilement là où vous êtes avantagé
c'est sur sur votre progression c'est
vrai qu'en comparant vous partirez de
plus bas mais votre salaire évoluera
plus vite dans le temps vous permettant
après quelques années de compenser cet
écart dans mon cas après mon bac + 8
j'ai perdu en salaire et je suis revenu
à mon salaire d'il y a 6 ans une perte
énorme alors quoi j'ai perdu mon temps
je me suis fait avoir es scroquerie pas
du tout en réalité il faut relativiser
tout ça premièrement les ouvertures
professionnelles pendant votre thèse
vous serez amené à rencontrer et à
échanger avec des professionnels c'est
très enrichissant pour vous et pour ils
se doivent de connaître les nouvelles
avancées de leur domaine et voudront
étudier vos travaux Seris sur le gâteau
ils savent que vous allez chercher un
emploi une fois votre thèse en poche qui
sont passés par là eux aussi et peuvent
vous guider même vous présenter à des
collègues travaillant dans le même
domaine que vous malheureusement vous
n'êtes pas le seul en France en 2021
13600 nouveaux docteurs célébrent déjà
leur diplôme sur la même période les
universités ont publié 1800 postes
d'enseignant chercheurs tout domaine
confondu même pas assez pour 15 %
d'entre eux et le recrutement se fait
sur concours autant vous dire que la
compétition est rude et le privé alors
plus de places plus de moyens c'est tout
BF surtout que depuis 19801 il existe le
ciifre non ce n'est pas une secte de
doctorant en façon Illuminati cela
permet à une entreprise de recevoir une
aide financière si elle confie un sujet
de thèse à un doctorant ainsi l'étudiant
est encadré dans un laboratoire
universitaire sur un sujet propre dans
l'entreprise le but est de renforcer
l'échange scientifique entre le domaine
public et le privé mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là c'est un premier pas dans le
monde du travail une fois la tèse
décrochée il est plus facile de se faire
recruter par l'entreprise vous avez déjà
travaillé pour eux pendant 3 ans sur un
projet long et difficile parfait il y en
a d'autres en réserve qui n'attendent
que vous et si vous décidez de tenter
votre chance dans une autre boîte et
bien c'est plus compliqué une thèse vous
spécialise sur un sujet très précis d'un
domaine des sciences pendant les
Entretiens on vous dira que vous êtes
même trop spécialisé pour faire autre
chose si là votre thèse ne porte pas sur
une thématique leur correspondant
parfaitement c'est game over utiliseer
votre réseau devient la clé pour ne
laisser passer aucune opportunité
deuxièmement la flexibilité
professionnelle après une thèse vous
êtes beaucoup plus flexible dans
l'apprentissage de nouvelles notions et
les employeurs le savent un de mes
meilleurs amis a effectué une thèse
assez dingue sur l'Internet du futur à
Osaka pourtant lorsqu'il est revenu en
France il a été embauché pour faire une
formation de 2 mois en Java pour
développer des outils et logiciels pour
les entreprises une transition rapide et
efficace qui a été rendu possible grâce
à l'autonomie de travail et la prise
d'initiative qu'inculte une thèse et la
meilleure de vos qualités et que vous
avez échoué c'est bien ça oui pour vous
en sortir il a fallu continuer vous avez
cherché des réponses et creuser là où
personne n'est allé regarder avant vous
impossible de faire avancer la science
sans passer par l'échec la plupart des
gens baissent les bras dans cette
situation et en ça vous vous démarquez
troisièmement les perspectives à
l'internationale beaucoup d'étudiants
partent faire leurs thèse à l'étranger
découvrir de nouvelles méthodes de
travail perfectionner son anglais il y a
plein de bonnes raisons mais une fois le
Doctor en poche faut-il rester revenir
si c'est pour la pine vaut mieux rester
de nombreux pays à travers l'Europe
rémunèrent bien mieux le bac plus suite
que la France en bleu vous voyez le
salaire moyen annuel d'un docteur et en
jaune les dépenses moyennes annuelles
pour une personne dans le pays il y a de
grosses disparités dans certains pays le
salaire n'est même pas suffisant pour
vivre ce n'est pas nouveau même le
directeur du poli a de Facebook le dit
et pourquoi les boîtes américaines ont
toujours un coup d'avance elles
dépensent plus d'argent dans la
recherche et elle pent bien les chercher
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fuite des
cerveaux et selon les domaines comme on
y a les écarts peuvent être énormes un
data aux USA c'est en moyenne plus de
10600 € par mois plus du double qu'en
Europe alors Go partir aux USA vivre le
rêve américain très peu pour moi la vie
n'est pas comme en France et je reste
attaché à ma vie et à mes projets ici la
thèse n'est-elle que le commencement le
soulagement de la fin de thèse après
plus de 3 ans de dur labeur la vie va
enfin pouvoir être paisible pas du tout
ce n'est que le début de l'enfer
maintenant que le monde du travail vous
attend CV entretien et cetera des
normalités sociales qui vont parfois
vous décevoir la vraie vie du monde pro
fait mal vous vous rendez compte que
votre profil trop théoricien rebute plus
d'un employeur ou que vous n'avez pas
les codes de plus les employeurs sont de
plus en plus demandeurs ça devient
difficile mais attendez ce n'est pas le
pire si vous décidez de rester dans la
recherche académique préparez-vous à
sacrifier une grosse partie de votre vie
dans ce milieu après la thèse on
effectue des années de postdoc de la
recherche temporaire où les salaires
sont parfois ralé prète la durée de ces
CDD peuv parfois être de 6 mois ou 1 an
juste pas suffisant pour faire de la
bonne recherche le but est de gagner en
expérience en participant aux échanges
internationaux de connaissance c'est
même primordial si vous souhaitez entrer
dans l'académique il faut prouver que
vous apportez quelque chose au monde de
la science par contre dans le privé
c'est vu d'un mauvais œil certaines
industries refusent même d'embaucher des
doctorants ayant effectué plus d'un
postdoc ce n'est pas une expérience
pertinente pour eux ils aiment cultiver
la culture de leurs entreprises chez
leurs employés quelques-uns ayant passé
trop de temps dans l'académique risqu
d'avoir des habitudes de travail ne
corresp respondont pas à leurs critères
du coup comment avoir un poste de
chercheur tout le problème est là dans
certains domaines scientifiques comme
les mathématiques la situation devient
catastrophique alors que faire après 6
se années de postdoc à travers le monde
puis- j'esérer un poste et me fixer dans
un pays tout ça dépend de vos
publications et de vos recherches après
ma thèse je n'avais publié qu'un seul
papier pas de quoi avoir un poste du
coup l'a prèthèse est le moment pour
consolider son dossier on publie on
présente on essaie de faire connaître
nos travaux c'est vraiment pas facile
sans qu'on fait tout pour t'enterrer
avec des délais de publication
totalement atroces mon premier article a
mis plus de 2 ans à être publié comment
veux-tu avoir une chance si au moment
des entretiens tes publications sont sur
liste d'attent aujourd'hui même je
continue mes publications dans cette
perspective mais avec mon travail et mes
autres activités c'est le parcours du
combattant du coup comment réussir après
la thèse déjà il faut accepter
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue
oui c'est difficile mais c'est le cas
pour tout le monde personne n'est
épargné donc il ne faut pas hésiter à
s'informer s'orienter là où il faut et
surtout persévérer et n'oubliez pas
qu'une multitude de métiers s'offre à
vous après une thèse donc vous avez
toutes vos chance ailleurs à quoi sert
un bac + 8 dans les entreprises je me
répète dans mon cas bac + 8 ça m'a
plutôt desservi sur l'aspect du salaire
mais pour trouver un travail faut pas
mentir ça aide bien mais concrètement
que disent les chiffres 3 ans après la
thèse le taux d'insertion à un emploi de
cadre est supérieur à 93 %. est-ce la
stabilité à vie pour autant non loin de
là un sur 3 n'auront toujours pas
d'emploi stable c'est normal lorsque
près de la moitié d'entre eux restent
dans l'académique et les autres ils vont
dans le privé puisque les compétences
que vous avez acquises sont très
recherché imaginez-vous à la tête d'une
équipe de recherche en entreprise
pharmaceutique décryptant les mystères
des virus pour créer un nouveau vaccin
ou encore concepteur en chef d'un
logiciel révolutionnaire sauf que la
grosse utilité salariale du bac plus
n'est pas pour vous mais directement
dans les poches de l'entreprise en
France on a le crédit impôt recherche
une déduction d'impôt qui permet aux
entreprises de récupérer 30 % de leur
coup lié à la red si elle embauche un
jeune docteur elle peut récupérer 120 %
de son salaire mais attention il y a des
conditions très strictes il faut que ça
soit une première embauche en CDI et
surtout l'entreprise doit augmenter son
nombre d'employés suite à l'embauche si
un chercheur part à la retraite et qu'il
est remplacé ça ne fonctionnera pas le
nombre d'employés est le même avant et
après l'embauche au final c'est un coup
de pouce mais jamais une raison d'ouvrir
un recrutement certains systèmes comme
la french tech ou les aides régionales
subventionnent les entreprises l'Europe
ouvre également des fonds afin de
promouvoir et pousser la recherche le
but est de les soutenir pour qu'elles
deviennent plus innovantes cela ouvre de
nouveaux postes pour les métiers de la
recherche sur lesquelles de jeunes
docteurs excellent les bac plus su
sont-ils encore utiles s'il y a de moins
en moins de plac en sortie de thèse
est-ce que c'est vraiment un métier
d'avenir et bien oui on entend souvent
dire que les nouvelles technologies vont
nous remplacer dans notre travail que
les IA penseront à notre place mais il
ne reste que des outil et pour s'en
servir et encrer de nouveau il faut des
chercheurs on attribue l'une des
premières intelligigen artificielle à
Christopher stchet en 1951 avant cela
très peu de recherches étent menées sur
le sujet pourtant aujourd'hui c'est un
domaine à part entière et beaucoup
d'efforts sont mis pour son
développement de nouvelles technologies
continueront à avir le jour et
nécessiteront des scientifiques
fraîchement formés comme avec
l'ordinateur quantique car c'est l'un
des gros avantages de sortir de thèse
apprendre grâce aux nouvelles méthodes
c'est apporter un œil neuf sur un
domaine qui peut sembler à l'arrêt et
les entreprises en ont besoin si elles
veulent rester à jour et compétitive
autant dire qu'un doctorat est
obligatoire pour effectuer de la
recherche sans ça votre candidature aura
très peu de chance d'être considérée il
faudra également enseigner aux nouveaux
étudiants et qui de mieux qu'un
spécialiste du domaine pour leur
apprendre pour cela il faudra plus de
postes ouverts mais la France cherche
des solutions ce privier de ses
chercheurs c'est perdre sa force
d'innovation et de toute compétitivité
technologique